lars klingbeil ist der spd-chef guten
tackling ball
koalitionskrach in der mega krise ist
das den leuten zu vermitteln
das ist kein krach wir haben eine
auseinandersetzung in der sache ich bin
robert habeck sehr dankbar dass er jetzt
bei der gasanlage auch gesagt hat da
wird nachgebessert das ist auch richtig
dass wir das tun es ist den menschen
nicht zu vermitteln dass unternehmen die
milliarden gewinne machen jetzt noch
milliarden steuergelder obendrauf
bekommen also da muss nachgebessert
werden und insgesamt ist es so dass die
regierung gerade mit hochdruck am
dritten entlastungspaket arbeitet und
ich bin mir sicher das wird sehr bald
kommen sehr bald sorgen sie wie schwer
all das für sie ist in der koalition das
merken wir auch daran dass dieser
zeitplan doch immer noch relativ unklar
ist die grünen wollen sehr sehr schnell
die fdp so wird das hat deutlich mehr
zeit wann wird denn dieses nächste
entlastungspaket konkret greifen können
es ist eine frage jetzt von tagen bis
das entlastungspaket dann in der
regierung in der koalition auf den weg
gebracht wurde verabschiedet wurde die
gespräche laufen ich finde richtig dass
jetzt im hintergrund laufen alle sagen
ja auch in diesen tagen was sie für
wichtig halten das muss ein großes paket
sein es muss zielgerichtet sein und es
muss den menschen vor allem
signalisieren wie bringen sie jetzt
vernünftig durch die nicht monate die
eine große herausforderung sind wir
haben uns bei zwei entlastungspaket
schon getan und das dritte kommt jetzt
dazu ein großes entlastungspaket haben
sie gerade eben gesagt der fdp chef
christian lindner sagt zitat kleinere
entlastungen könne es womöglich noch
dieses jahr geben größere aber erst 2023
das werden wir jetzt im detail
besprechen ein paar dinge liegen auf dem
tisch die massive ausweitung beim
wohngeld das bürgergeld auch die frage
der steuerlichen entlastung ich glaube
allerdings wir müssen ein fehler aus dem
letzten
entlastungspaket korrigieren wir haben
da die rentnerinnen und rentner
vergessen die sind auch hart betroffen
von den energiepreisen die gerade nach
oben gehen wir müssen etwas für die
studentinnen und studenten tun und ich
sagte ja noch ganz klar im mittelpunkt
stehen diejenigen die hart arbeiten die
jeden tag zur arbeit gehen die 1500 2000
euro im monat haben
für die brauchen wir jetzt auch
substanzielle entlastung das alles muss
jetzt zusammen gebracht werden und es
muss schnell gehen es muss jetzt
zusammen gebracht werden und es muss
schnell gehen die zeit drängt in der tat
auch wegen der
haushaltsberatungen im bundestag
er ging weil dass der tank rabatt am
mittwoch aus laufen würde das war ja
klar dass das neue neurotiker zum
beispiel am mittwoch ebenfalls ausläuft
das war auch klar warum gibt es dann
zwei tage davor er noch immer keine
klarheit ob und was genau danach kommt
wir haben ja beim neuen euro ticket ganz
klare signale jetzt auch der
verkehrsminister sagte air will jetzt
eine weiterführung suchen die jetzt für
die bundestagsfraktion die sich ja jetzt
gestern auch deutlich positioniert hat
sagt dass auch und auch die grünen sagen
dass also insofern bin ich sehr
optimistisch ländern sagen mir dass er
mit der finanzierung die sie da geplant
haben nicht verstanden sind insofern
gibt es da auch noch wahnsinnig viel
diskussion sind darf offensichtlich und
keine klare regel auf die die leute sich
jetzt in dieser schwierigen lage auch
verlassen könnten und mit der sie planen
könnten
es ist eine krise die nicht geplant war
eine krise in der wir gerade im laufen
entscheiden müssen aber was wir
hinbekommen haben sind zwei große
entlastungspaket ich sage ihnen wir sind
alle gewillt auch das 9 euro ticket eine
art und weise vorzuführen dass muss
jetzt aber mit den ländern geklärt
werden aber das signal dass weitere
entlastung kommen darauf können sich die
bürgerinnen und bürger verlassen gut sie
haben gerade schon vorhin kurz
angesprochen hat klingt weil die
gasanlage da sollen wir jetzt also alle
gemeinsam alle gaskunden wichtige
gasversorger retten und merken
gleichzeitig dass wir auch die
unterstützen die selbst kräftig geld
machen wie naiv ist es denn in der
politik darauf zu hoffen dass
geschäftsleute wenn der staat ihnen die
möglichkeit dazu gibt nicht auch mal zu
geschäftemachern werden
die begründung für diese gasanlage die
mir gesagt wurde war es geht darum
insolvenzen abzuwenden
was nicht geht ist dass gewinne
maximiert werden was nicht geht ist dass
steuergelder noch auf milliardengewinne
oben drauf gepackt werden robert habeck
hat jetzt gesagt er lässt prüfen wie man
diese unternehmen nicht unterstützt das
muss entweder politisch entschieden
werden oder es wird in der verordnung
entschieden am ende hat der bundestag
auch das schlusswort und ich sage ganz
klar ist kann nicht sein dass diese
unternehmen die milliarden gewinn machen
dass die noch steuergeld obendrauf
bekommen das gibt auch eine schieflage
in der bevölkerung ich habe heute haben
eine große veranstaltung im wahlkreis
gehabt die menschen merken dass da gibt
es widerspruch und deswegen darf das
nicht sein und es muss verhindert werden
jetzt reden sie allerdings so als sei es
noch gar nicht als verordnung
beschlossen worden es ist ja bereits in
der diskussion seit wochen diese ganze
geschichte und es drängt sich ein
bisschen der eindruck auf dass je
schneller es geht desto mehr fehler
passieren in der bundesregierung ich sag
nur erst der tank rabatt und dann die
hoffnung dass die mineralölkonzerne
ihnen weiter geben mögen die korona
testzentren das war die letzte regierung
ohne kontrolle in der hoffnung das wäre
dann jeder auch sauber hinterher
abrechnen ist nicht passiert wie wir
heute wissen ist nicht absehbar dass
solche hochschule geschichten bei denen
es aber um milliarden von euros geht
dann am ende auch ausgenutzt werden
es passieren in der tat fehler und ich
sehe das jetzt meine aufgabe als
parteivorsitzender fehler die ich
wahrnehme deutlich anzusprechen
korrekturen einzufordern aber ich sage
ihnen auch ich habe hohen respekt vor
einer regierung die von tag eins sofort
mit großen krisen belastet war die große
krisen die nicht absehbaren als diese
regierung zusammengekommen ist die mit
diesen krisen zu handeln hat da gibt es
vieles für das gibt es kein drehbuch da
können fehler in der tat passieren
wichtig ist für mich dass wir die kraft
haben das auszusprechen und dass wir
dann die kraft haben die fehler schnell
zu korrigieren
das tut robert habeck jetzt das ist
richtig und in meinen augen muss politik
in krisenzeiten
genauso auch funktionieren einige
dürften keine fehler gemacht werden wenn
sie gemacht werden dann müssen sie
schnell korrigiert werden sagt der spd
chef lars klingbeil vielen dank
sehr gerne